ils ne m'ont pas tué mais ils ne l'ont pas fait
même pas parti avant
[Musique]
Je vis parmi la police et les juges maintenant
il y a tellement de voitures blindées dans celle-ci
situation que je ne ressens pas personnellement
rien si je devais aller chez roberto di
26 ans je lui dirais de faire pareil avec plus
mise en garde
[Musique]
et donc croire qu'il peut avoir peur de
bouffon n'est pas mon style mais un
ministre menaçant de supprimer
protection et théâtre
je le veux des élections je ne le veux pas
J'ai hâte de le perdre et d'être à nouveau libre
la protection n'est pas un privilège c'est un
drame
en fait toute l'histoire du roman
inspiré par des faits réels pour la première fois
à l'Ouest un groupe d'adolescents
ils ont réussi en quatre ans à
monter au sommet de l'un des plus
grandes organisations criminelles du
monde des 10 et 19 ans
nicolas fiorillo dans mon roman
emanuele sibillo chef de la paranza dei
enfants de ceux qui dans la traduction font
ils appelleraient piranha
c'était un garçon brillant à certains égards
génie qui devient sanguinaire
le plus féroce cruel du monde ripa
razzini pour les garçons des groupes
les criminels sont divisés entre vissés et vissés
taureaux fi injustice ou souffre
injustices il n'y a pas de troisième voie
[Musique]
de tiret adorent l'irrationalité de
violence pour tuer tout le monde et puis mourir je
points de contact entre djihadistes e
Camorra et surtout dans la syntaxe
de la violence s'y développent
barbe les garçons napolitains de la paranze
ils écrivent au de barra même s'ils sont
tous les catholiques
la mort est toujours présente dans la tienne
la vie après ta vie
si nécessaire pour démontrer avec eux
mort qui qui a fait des choses qui
ils comptent
cette jeunesse est perdue parce qu'elle n'a pas
alternatives pour améliorer alternatives
juste pour survivre et l'heure
vision, puis décider de prendre
ce que veulent ceux qui sont déformés
[Musique]
si écrire mal veut dire
alors il faudrait répandre le mal
brûler toute l'histoire de
Littérature
Je pense à tout sauf à dire
mauvais de dire la blessure n'est pas un
moyen de répandre le mal, mais en effet pour
tournez-le quiconque regarde le
parrain devient mafieux parce qu'il avait
vu le parrain doit déjà être dedans
environnement mafieux